طائرات الاحتلال قامت بقصف هذا المنزل في
منطقه بلوك 2 منزل يعود لعائله خليل هناك
عدد كبير من الشهداء والاصابات في المكان
هنا
اطفال هناك عدد من الشهداء والاصابات يا
الله
عدد كبير من الاطفال ومن النساء في هذا
المكان
صورصور صور
[موسيقى]
روحوا الدمار الدمار كبير جدا في
المكان عدد الشهداء هنا يتم انتشال عدد من
المواطنين من تحت
الركام الله
علت عمليات البحث
مستمره عن عدد
كبير في هذا
المكان
تحت حسبي الله ونعم الوكيل في اليهود حسبي
الله ونعم الوكيل الصف هؤلاء الاطفال تحت
القصف هؤلاء الاطفال 70 ل 80 نف كلهم
اطفال كلهم نساء وكلهم عزل م لهم اي حاجه
ولهم اي شغله قاعدين في بيتنا ما شفنا
الدار بتنزل عليه 25 يوم بره لما رجعوا
الناس كليتهم لمعسكر جبل رجعنا وقعدنا في
بيتنا وكل صار ان نحنا قاعدين في بيتنا لا
طالعين ولا نزلين ما شفنا البيت كله بينزل
عليه حسبي الله وانت نعم الوكيل عدد
الاطفال اللي فيه فوق 35 واحد هذا سابق
انظار واحنا قاعدين ما بنعرف هذا عمل
اجرامي عمل بربري عمل وحشي هذا العمل اللي
قاموا فيه الاسرائيليين يفوق عمل النج هذ
ناس عزل ما قدروا على المقاومه يكتف الناس
العزل الناس الابرياء طبعا هنا محاوله
انتشال طفل من تحت
الركام هات هات ها الان تم انتشال هذا
الطفل حي من تحت ركام هذا
[تصفيق]
المنزل مازال الاهالي يحاولون الوصول لعدد
كبير من المواطنين هنا بعد قصف الاحتلال
هذا المنزل على رؤوس ساكنيه المنزل ماهول
بالسكان وحسب شهود عيان من هذا المنزل
هناك عدد كبير مازالوا مفقودين تحت الركام
هنا الاهالي بايديهم يحاولون النبش من اجل
انتشال عدد كبير من الاطفال ومن
النساء
شباب
الراحه انس الشريف الجزيره شمال غزه